this is a production of cornell
university
yes thank you so much wojtek for your
introduction um
thank you for the organizers to give me
opportunity to share some part of my
project with you
today i will tell you
about the meiotic recombination how to
track and how to
answer the question
how the myotic recombination works in
mace
but before i will go into
the
molecular part of it i will tell you
what is a molecular meiotic
recombination it's a process of the
genetic material exchange
in paren which are going to the
offspring we have the two homologous
chromosomes marked in blue and red then
in the crossover process in the meiotic
recombination they are passed to each
other and later
they are transferred into the offspring
and we can use this feature
later to
create
the elite germplasms with the new
combination of traits we can have the
gene part
responsible for draft resistance insect
resistance or increase the yield
and simple
if we will
understand
how works the landscape and decision
process of the meiotic recombination
then we can try to control it and make
our own
new elite drone plasmas and we can
accelerate the breeding process which
already take years and cost millions
um chemical recombination takes place in
the process called meiosis in the mayo
site the mayor's is subdivided for the
many different stages
sub-stages
starting in the leptotin here you have
the
dna
genomic dna composed by
two chromos two homologous chromosomes
marked by red and blue
the first step is actually doing the
double strand break by the 411 then this
double string break is processed to have
the
overhangs single stranded overhangs in
the zygote
and this overhang start to invade
the homologous chromatid and create
the intermediate
of the cross of the
crossover intermediate and this
intermediate
is going into the non-crossover which is
like gene conversion the short fragment
only is exchanged or
bigger fragment in the crossover
type of exchange
the later these crossovers are visible
in the diplo team under the microscope
you can see how the two chromatids are
connected together
only on the
disjunction on this connection of the
crossover
and they are resolved in the diagnosis
stage
then our
question is how the meiosis is regulated
how the meiotic recombination is
regulated
how from
300 to 500 dsb
high number of the of the zsb's at the
end we have only 10 exchanges or 2 to 20
exchanges of the genetic material the
crossover
and why this exchanges take place
mostly
on the terminus part of the chromosome
we have elevated numbers of the
crossovers
at the distal part of the chromosomes
however
the
central part
is
limited of it but there is a lot a lot
of the interesting
genes which are useful for the breeding
okay and how to answer these questions
i was
looking on graph and we found that there
is mlh3 protein
which take which is engaged in the
initiation of the recombinant
initiation of the
establishment of the intermediates they
are going for the proceed process of
these intermediates in the packeting and
finally
the emergency still engaged in the
resolution of the crossover
and the numbers of mlh3 in a process of
meiosis is going down through the
progression of the prophase one
thing that we we have the pictures here
microscopic picture
where we have the red dots is emily
shree staining on the zygote in stage
where the number is around 30 40 50
goes into the lower number in the
packaging where in the packaging i hope
you can see
there is this spaghetti stuff
there are chromosomes combined together
there are synapses each each other
and the the the dots as actually where
the crossovers take place
and in diagnosis what i was telling you
about this
junction this connection of the
homologous chromosomes
uh these chiasmata sites are marked by
the mlh3
and we what we can see
there is a selective processing of this
crossover intermediates
what is happening why from 50 from from
the beginning of 40 from the beginning
of mlh 3 we have at the end
only few
which marks exactly the crossovers
but what is about h3
a partner of mlh1 and they together
create the complex called mutel
a gamma they interact with the several
different
meiotic recombination
proteins
the down regulation results in the
sterility of semi severity in many
organisms and have has a function in
dna repair and also in the meiotic
recombination what i was telling you
already
the method the tool for tracking this
protein um
what i use in my studies is
chromatin immunoprecipitation followed
by the next generation sequencing
and here you have the particle
of the dna
which will
symbolize here as a recombination
intermediate dna the red one will be the
place where the recombination takes
place and we have the intermediates of
it in the zygote in stage as i said this
establishment of these intermediates
then later in the packet and we have the
stabilization and diagnosis we have the
resolution but in all these three stages
we have the mlh3 on the place
and when we take the male size the
tissue from this particular stages we
are able
to pull down this protein
the process looks like this we have the
mlh3 on the particular stage we cross
link this with the cross-linking agent
we do the fragmentation to have the
smaller fragment we pull down this with
the specific antibodies
and release the dna and we can figure it
out where
the intermediates
were or
where the crossovers is
okay um
but before there was no commercial
available
antibodies and create our own
recombinant proteins
uh called mlh3n and mlh3c are getting
the specific terminal side of the mlh3
we send this for immuno immunization of
of rabbit and guinea pig and we obtain
the antibodies we test these antibodies
on a slide this is a packaging in mace
and what we saw we were very happy
because
we hope only one will work but we have
the two antibodies working and they
colloquialized very well
here on the on the slides and we were
very happy because we have the internal
control saying that if the one antibody
will show us something and okay maybe
it's a noise but if two on the same side
there's
something
uh meaningful
then
the another
because this was on the slide under the
microscope but we have done also chip
and compared the sides of the mlh3 c and
n and we got the eighty percent of the
peaks from both
overlapping each other in the zygotin 63
in the packaging and in die plotting
around 80 percent
and where are the speaks where are the
the intermediates and what are the
crossovers
so
remove
here now i want to get rid of the
yeah this one
okay uh
now we have someone on on
uh
the chat box which i
it looks very different on the mac when
i
when i do it
so the person on the chat box could you
send me an email to wp45
then i can check in my phone
okay thank you voiko for helping me with
this um the emily stream the zygotin is
actually distributed along of the
chromosomes this is a ten mace
chromosomes combined into one where we
have the starting tiloma and end of the
tiloma and in the middle we have the
centromere and this is a distribution of
mlh three peaks along of the of the same
chromosomes combined together in one
graph
and what we can see in zygote in we have
everywhere
oh
yeah but now i cannot go
next slide
okay that should be good
okay i'm sorry
um
and this distribution is very similar
for the distribution of double span
breaks
which is very nice because we have
something which is looking like
something in the zeiger scene but later
in the packaging we have much more peaks
on the distal part of the chromosome on
the chromosome ends which is mimicking
the
crossover pattern
saying that we we see the the
characteristic typical for the dsb in
youngest stages of the manasis and the
crossovers in the later simply we try to
assure ourselves we are on the track and
we are finding the good things and later
when we go to the fine scale and we
check the mlh3c and n in the different
genic on non-genic region and utrs which
is um untranscriptional origins
where
the the the the percentages of mlh3
corresponds to the real crossovers
mapped by the genetic mapping and you
can see we have like like a 10
to 15 where it's where is the control
here we have the 15 and to 10 but here
in the genic region we have very similar
like a 25 percent in total for the mlh3
and 25 for
for the crossovers around 50
for the intergenic and 50 for the
positive control and completely
different than the
negative control
then
how good is the military in detecting
the crossovers
and it will take the 500 the strongest
peaks in my chip we are able to detect
more than 50 percent of the crossovers
compare with the negative control is
around 50
in all all stages
but
i was asking and where is the other chi
where are the other peaks and we start
to validate um
the map
of
where are the hits and the hits were in
the s p desert because in traditional
genetical mapping this means how the
people are checking where are the
crossovers they simply take the one
inbred b73 and the second inbred most
17. they know where are the single
nucleotides polymorphism or where are
the indels and simply
later they do it the hybrid and they
sequence the hybrid and they know okay
this part is from the chromosome a
here we have the s p from b
and we know here is a crossover
well
um
somewhere here
but sometimes we have the crossover
which is out from um
close by s p or indel
and we found that the more than 40
percent 40 more than 45 percent of the
total pixel family she comes from
this desert
simply
probably
we are able to detect the crossover but
current reference map what we were using
uh was too low resolute the resolution
was too loud to detect it
and
using
maybe we can overcome now this
limitation i mean we don't have to use
the s and ps and we create the first
time ever the crossover input inbred
line
where we don't use any hybrid and it's
it's very robust and efficient
we have the different window sides here
and we compare this with the num
population which is
uh
nested association mapping
created by the b73 crossed with the
multiple inbred lines
and we got
we compared this uh
this side of the crossovers with our
mlh3 and we got more than 65
but still we can have some limitation
because of the resolution of our
reference crossover map in the packaging
we can also see there is more elevated
speaks on the digital part of the
chromosome
the
if we had finally the the peaks from the
b73 we start to analyze where are the
speaks and we found the
motifs associated with this uh
mlh3 binding site and we found like a
polytimidine
site or very very conserved high
specific
sequence
our palidromic sequence
and when we try to check and validate
where are these polydromic and where are
this
highly specific sequence we found that
they are coming from the 180 repeats of
knobs and knobs
are very highly
heavily methylated and very
condensed heterochromatin structures you
can see here on the picture with the
mlh3 staining inside
um
but
and this was surprising for us because
the metal the crossovers from the
previous studies we know the crossovers
doesn't like
um
the methylation and do not like the
heterochromatin however 25 percent of
the total peaks was coming from the knob
sites
um
yeah but not all of them when you can
see the chromosome 8 we have here the
map of of the repeats and the red is
marking where are the repeats and the
blue where we have the
uh the hits from mlh3 we are still on
the way to analyze this
there is also the two features
which one i was mentioning the the metal
lesion is associated with the crossover
and the second one is the terachromatin
which is also associated with the
nucleus um
position simple how many nucleosomes is
there and how dense is chromatin does
and we found that in the zygotin and
pocketing we have slight transition in
the in the peak here we have the medial
binding peak or binding site of the mlh3
which is
narrower than the the
the packeting saying that we have some
kind of the selection pressure to more
relaxed chromatin less saturated of the
nucleus on this position
when we go to the methylation studies we
see
we have three different type of the
methylation in plants which is
predominantly cg and chg where the the h
is everything except g
um
the dotted line is reference of the
genome
the cg and ceg
is here where they down regulated in the
zygote in the binding site of mlh3 the
chh
there's only like a two three percent of
the total methylation
is a little bit elevated but we see the
transition and some preference for the
sites which present the deep
of
methylation types in the cg
and chg
and
elevated
signal from
chh which is quite interesting we have
some kind of the selective pressure for
these sites which shows the typical
characteristics in these two pictures
then how
may this is regulated we have
from 300 to 500 dsb then later on we
have the resection
map
which we are also working about
then we have the zygote map of mlh3
where we have the 3050 and then we have
the transition for the specific sequence
also for the knobs
we have the
nucleosome depletion factor which is
also preference for for being a
crossover reduction in cg and chg and
increase of the chhhh
and finally at the end we have the
crossover
well
to sum up this everything mlh3
detects the crossover side with the high
accuracy
in hybrid and
it's possible to use this in the inbred
in the pure lines i mean we don't have
artificial crosses but we can do it in
the
in the pure line
um this really reveals several types of
the
binding associated motifs
um it's much cheaper the method is much
cheaper more accurate we can do it on
the nucleotide resolution scale
uh it's much robust we can survey a
million of crossovers inside of the
thousands and much cheaper you don't
have to build the population and
sequence a lot
um and the psychological and cheap data
show us
that the mlh3
has a role in the crossover
non-crossover decision and also the
cataract chromatin
the chromatin features and sequence
features like knob and nucleus and
density
may
um
push
for the selection pressure to for for
the crossover
um at the end i would like to
thank you so much for mingui wang
who is doing this all magic with the
bioinformatics data kaska for helping me
with the with the wet
bench work uh
for his experience
uh and sharing of the knowledge
uh
thank you nsf for for founding cornell
for hosting and thank you all for your
attention
uh very nice talk so could you just go
back to uh the slides showing the
distribution of mlh
mlh3 binding targets
at three different
crossover stage
you know
yeah so this one so we can see the
cyclogen so distribution of the
mlh3 binding so it's a little different
from other two stages so this one other
two stages basically they have more
you know
uh
finding targets at the distal range of
the
problem
[Music]
the question is why we have the
difference in in distribution in zygote
and packaging and whether do i i'm able
to explain it
um
the the zygote in peaks which is a long
of the chromosome is mimicking the dsps
and i think they are simple they are
combining
uh in the processing of the early stage
of the meiotic recombination
saying that it's still sitting here on
the ds this is a data from rad51 which
is csb marker and simply we can see this
along of the chromosome
it's this is also related with some
histone marks which are preferable for
uh for rat51 and what i can say
is that this
first we have plenty of the dsb they are
everywhere but later on we have the
transition into the into the sides which
which shows these features what i was
showing later this uh this nucleosome
occupancy
and methylation state
um i don't know what do i explain
okay
so
so this distribution pattern is um
similar to different
you know like ps73 or ammo is there a 17
or or just specific to
certain genotypes certain background
we tested only b73 but
i would say this is
and this is common for the all different
ingredients okay uh for for the
crossover distribution in in mace
there's always u-shape we have more
on the digital part and less in the
central region or intersectional region
i should know this but i don't but um
what's the cause of the double strand
breaks
what is the cost the double strain
breaks yeah this is a what is the cause
of the double string break is that um
because if you would like to have the
exchange of the of the genetic material
and finally to have some
um
um simple evolution itself
then you need to do the first step to
cut the dna and simple somehow
physically
allow this process to to happen
that's why we cut one and two to have
the
the invasion later on and exchanges to
have the crossover is it an enzymatic um
action or is it physical is it enzymatic
mediated by this 411 protein big program
no more question let's take my toes
[Applause]
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu